ものすごい世の中でこれほど難しいことはないんです
これワスカでもできるというのは
他のことって何のことなくできるんですよ
外科の先生のような感じで
一つ一つ別々になんか自分という考え方を全くなしにして見られるという
大変な仕事だから このアビダンマという膨大な知識の世界が現れてきて
それを説明しようとしているし
お経読んでみたって瞑想はできますけどね
お経ではそれなりに簡単にわかりやすく瞑想できるしやすくようには一応指導はまたあるし
ですから我々にはいくらかこの心の状態を理解できるというならば
それで結構なんですね
例えば自分が物惜しみの心が生まれたら
やっぱり私は嫉妬深い人だとかね
そう思う必要ない 物惜しみだったら嫉妬がないんだと
対象が違うんだと こういうものについて自分が物惜しみが生まれているんだっていうふうな理解なんですね
必要な なんか自分がうまくいってるだろうなと思ったら慢なんですね
その時は貪りの心ですよと
貪瞋痴だよと マーナが貪瞋痴に生まれるんだから
マーナがあるとディッティがない
見がないんですね だからそういうふうな理解なんですね
で まあそういうことで
まああまり聞かない方がいいんです
で 真剣にやれる瞑想なんですよ
これもう大変 世の中でも
生命にある一番難しいことはヴィパッサナーをすること
物事を客観的にありのまま観察すること
それが一番難しい 思うほど簡単じゃないんです
ですから 一歩ずつ一歩ずつ順番に見ておけば
一番難しいことをしているんだから
一番この生命がやるべき仕事
本物をやってるんだから
他の何よりも効き目がある
ヴィパッサナーがうまく行ってもいかなくても
他の修行はもう何十年やるよりも
これはもう効き目がある
いきなり問題にぶつかっているんだから
準備じゃないんだ 準備瞑想じゃないんだから
そういうことで このつまらなくなったとかはありえないんですよ
できなくなったとかね
24時間もできるんです
いくらチャレンジしたっても
山はそれでも大きいんです
だからやり方見つかっちゃったらね
自分で  それを自分で発見するしかないんですね
いくら言っても意味が
例えば客観的に見ろと言っても
みんな主観的に見えちゃうでしょうに
客観的に見ると もうみるみるうちに心が変わっていっちゃうんです
自分でもわかるように
じりじりと自分の性格が変わって変わっていくんですよ
たった 1 分でもいいんですよ
客観的に見られたら みるみるうちに自分がもう変わってしまう
だから言葉では言いやすい
客観的に見ましょうと
でも いくら言葉で言いやすくたっても
人間は主観的に見る 怒りが怒りばっかりだから
本当に嫌ですよと そういう反応でしょ
今日は妄想ばっかしで嫌でしたとかね
うまくいかなかったとかね
今日は眠気が出て 本当にもう大変きつかったとかね
全部主観的に見てるんですね
嫌かきつかった 良くなったかという反応はあるはずがないんですよ
客観的に見たら そこの私にもどうすることもできないんです
私にじゃなくて 瞑想指導者にはね
それで言えるのは それも確認しておいてください
それも確認しちゃうと
ほんのわずかのそれ救いなんですよ
それも確認しちゃったら
ちょっと主観的な状態がちょっと弱くなっちゃうんですね
気持ち悪くなりましたと
面白くなったと うまくいったと思ったと
思ったと過去にラベリングしちゃったら
主観的なエネルギーがいくらか弱くなるんです
だからそれも確認しろという一言葉しか指導者には言えないんです
それも確認してくださいと
相手が何言おうとか ですから
瞑想指導はその点では随分簡単ですよ
相手が一生懸命いろんなことを言うかもしれませんだけど
それも じゃあそれも確認してくださいと
ですから この確認できるようなこの心の状態
確認できるようなぐらいの真書の勉強で十分だなと思います
ということで  第3章に進みます
70ページの それをパキンナカと言って
別にあるテーマでまとめたわけじゃなくて
理解しておいた方がなんとか便利じゃないっていうふうな意味でまとめているところなんですね
その場合は 心も心所も別に区別するわけじゃなくて
大体心象の世界ですから
全部心の勉強っていうのはないし
ですから心象の勉強なんですけど
まあいろいろ理解した方がいいなということで
ヴェーダナーへととキッチェドアラーランベナワットとチットウッパダワセーネーヴェサンガホーナーマニーヤテ
そこでこういうカテゴリーに入れるんです
えーと 今それは心身処法のサスの何でしたっけ
説ですかね 説なるものが受・院・作用・門・所縁・起・生起というカテゴリーに分けて説明するんだと
で これからは別に心と心所っていうのを別に考えることじゃなくて
一緒にまとめて考えちゃうんです
1番目はヴェーダナーサンガーハ
受の説
タッタ・ヴェーダナー・サンガー・エターヴァ・ティヴィダー・ヴェーダナー・スカン・ドゥッカ・アドゥッカ・マ・スカン・チャ・チ・チェーティ・スカン・ドゥッ
カ・ソーマナッサン・ドーマナッサン・ウペッカー・アティチャ・デーデーナ・パナ・パンチャ・ダーホーティと
で ヴェーダナーという言葉
その言葉自体は大変大事なんです
ヴェーダナー ヴェーダナーというのは感じるという意味なんですね
これ中村先生は感受という言葉を入れてますからね
感受性 感受性といえば
現代日本語でわかりやすいと思いますよ
感受性 感じることなんですね
仏教専門用語では受だけ書いてますけどね
受だけでは意味は通らないかもしれませんだけどね
でも原文では一つの言葉だから
漢字では二つの言葉を入れるわけにはいきませんということで
この一つの漢字だけ当てはめちゃうんですね
このヴェーダナーというのは
仏教哲学の世界では 仏教哲学じゃなくて
釈尊の世界観ではこれはキーワードなんです
それはキーワードであって
もう存在のもう何といいますかね
存在というものを解明するときのキーワード
それなんです それさえ理解しておけば
もうもう全く違う哲学が生まれてくるんです
で どういうことでしょうかね
このヴェーダナーって
感受というのは それはこういうこと
で 私はよく言いますね
この生き物と生きていないもの
いわゆる生命体と物体はどうやって区別するかと
心の区別の場合は これは生きている生き物と言えば
そこに心の働きがあるんだと
これはただの物体というと
それは生き物ではないんですね
ただの物質の塊 そこで物質の塊と生命の・生命という物質の塊
区別する場合は この区別できる働きは心の働きなんですし
それよりはこの生命という我々生命という物体がいろんなものに反応するんですね
外の世界に反応する あるいは自分の体に反応する
これどちらかに反応する
瞑想の立場から言えば
瞑想を始める人々はいつでも外の世界
世界に反応する いい場所を探すは
音が入らない場所を探すは
もう外からずいぶん影響を受けちゃう
瞑想進んだら 音があってなくても全然気にしない
座ってる場所は暗い場所であろうが
明るい場所全く関係ないと
道路の側であろうか 部屋の中では関係なく瞑想できるんだけど
その場合は自分の体に反応するんですよ
座ったらすぐもう体のもう感覚がもう現れてくる
音が音には反応しない
外の音が入ったってさてはいらない
もう別に それよりは体の感覚は分かってるんだから
ですから この生命という物体が外の世界に反応するか
自分の体に反応するか
どっちかしてるんですね
両方をしている どっちかではなくて
それで反応する この働きは受と言えるんですね
で わかりやすく考えてみましょう
目があって 目は光に反応する
それは受なんですね 耳が音に反応する
それは受と言うんですね
体が硬さと温度に反応する
それは受と言うんです
妄想が入ったら複雑なんですけど
妄想なくしに考えちゃうと
体が硬さと温度だけに反応する
他の何にも反応しない
音にも反応しない 我々は妄想の中にいるんだから
もう大変なんですよ これは柔らかいとか
これは硬いとかね これはギザギザのものやとかね
これは重いとか あ これはずいぶん軽いとか
それ全部体で感じるものでしょうに
今日はホカホカして気持ちがいいとか
今日はなんかちょっと暑いんじゃないかなとかね
今日はなんか肌寒いですよとか
今日はずいぶん冷えますよとか
我々の妄想の世界ではもういろんな言葉があるんですが
実際にこの皮膚が硬さと温度にしか反応しない
目はまあ光から まあ光は単なるこの情報通達するものだけですけど
形に反応するんです 光に反応するんじゃなくて
ですから アビダンマはあれほど厳密に物質論を語っているのに
目に触れるのは光ですよ
全然一言も言って 私だけがそれをずっと言っているのは
それは私の頭がこの西洋の知識から汚染されているんだから
西洋の科学的な知識が入ってない坊さんたちは全然言わない
そんなこと 目で見ているのは光ですよと言わない
光見えないんです 光見えるんだったら
この部屋の真ん中見えるはずでしょうに
部屋の真ん中見えますか？見えないでしょうに
光見えるんだったら 人はもうとんでもない
歩けなくなっちゃうんですよ
どこにも光あるんだから
だからこの光見えるっていうのは全くの間違いであって
光は目 形に反応する だからそれは西洋的な解釈でいうと
ある形にあるものに光がぶつかって
もう何て言いますか 反応してくるでしょ
反射して その反射してくる光は形をとってるんですよ
その取っている形に我々の目が反応するんです
あれは机だと 光には反応しない
で 光にも形があるんだから
当然光にも反応しますけど
その時も形なの 例えば自分の目にちゃんと両目に懐中電灯を２つちゃんとつけてみると
まぶしくて何も見えないんだけど
そこで懐中電灯から光がある形で出るでしょうに
それに反応しているんです
太陽もまあもうあんまいくらか曇りで覆っている時はね
見えますからね 太陽は光いっぱい出してるものでしょうし
でもその時は太陽の形に反応するんですよ
真ん丸くて 光には反応しない
光は全然通るんであって
全然知らない 例えば我々の部屋の左側からある光を右側に出したと
そこで左側の光も光の出しているライトを見えないように後ろに入れていると
そこで穴から光が出て
右側の壁にも穴があって
ピッタリその穴から抜けていくんだと
行ったら見えないでしょ
そうしたら見えない もし左側の壁にライトが見えるんだったら
こちらからこのライトから光がこの壁の穴から通っていくなというふうに推測するだけで
その場合はライトの形が見える
もしそのライトは右側の壁に当たっているならば
当たっている形が見えるんだけど
真ん中の光は見えない
そこで実験なんですけど
ライトは見えないようにさらに壁の後ろに持っていく
壁の後ろに持っていって
壁の穴から光だけ出しちゃう
出す光はきちんとまっすぐ線で行って
前の穴から抜けると 右側の壁の穴から抜けると
ですから 右側の穴が結構大きくしちゃえば大丈夫ですからね
あるいはレンズを使って光を絞っておけばだいぶ大丈夫でしょうに
そうすると我々は何も見えないんですよ
本当は部屋の中 ずっと強烈な光が流れてるんです
これ１００ワットにしても
2000ワットにしても見えない
5000ワットにしても
ここから出て ここから目の前を通っているのに
その間に何か入れちゃったら
もうすごい光だとすぐ気づくんですよ
例えば自分が外を出ようと思ったところで
自分がこの光の線を横切ると
その時びっくりする あ
すごい光ですねとびっくりするんですよ
ですから 目が反応するのは形に反応
というのは仏教の考え方なんです
あれほどきめ細かく物質する喋ってるんだから知っていたんだから
このもう素粒子のレベルで
なんでヨーロッパの物理学者が言ってる基本的な単純なことも知らないんですかね
この人 そんなにも甘いもんじゃないんです
我々から見ればそちらの方がまだまだもうよちよち歩きですよと
光は見えないと 見えるのは形だよと
ですから形に反応する
音に耳が反応する 体が熱と硬さに反応する
重いっていうのは硬さなんですよ
軽いっていうのはまた同じ硬さ
言葉だけ違うんであって
それは頭で考えて そういう言葉
重いというと 何か軽いものを想像して妄想で全部
これは重いと これ軽いと言っちゃったら
すぐ何かこの服は軽くというのはとか
バカバカしい 何に？何に比べて軽いというんですかね
ですから 本当に知恵が鋭い人だったら
あっ これ軽くっていいわという瞬間に
自分が何と比べているかと
すぐ頭にあるはずなんで
それあったら随分頭いいんですよ
例えばラーメン このラーメン美味しいやと
あんな馬鹿げた話を言うんじゃなくて
私は先週なんとか店で食べたラーメンと比べると美味しいやと言った方が
言わなくたってもすぐ頭にその基準がね
浮かんだらもう本当の知恵の鋭い人なんですよ
だから知恵とやっぱり記憶力つなげてるんです
だから知恵ある人には記憶力あるんです
記憶力っていうのはもう全く簡単なものなんです
覚えるっていうのは大変な仕事なんですから
記憶力じゃないんです
で なんか違うやり方なんですけどね
で できるようになったら知恵とつなげて
だから何か記憶力 記憶したい記憶したければ知恵を使うしかないんです
物を覚えてこないんだったら知恵使ってください
知恵使っちゃうと覚えなくてもいいんです
もう記憶力そこにあるんです
それいろいろ工夫ありますけどね
で 普通の教育の世界では理解してくださいと
覚えなくてもいいんだから
例えば外国語を教える場合は
単語のあれ 何て言いますか
このリスト書いて覚えたりするでしょ
あれで上手にならないんです
忘れちゃいます そういうふうに覚えるものは
そうじゃなくて その単語ではなくて
それを体験する なんとかの方法で
そうすると忘れられないんですね
そうすると単語の数が少ないかもしれませんだけど
その人にその言葉は使えるんです
で 私勉強した時はね 周りの友達方はみんな結構勉強できてる連中ばっかりでしたからね
大学生の友達ばっかりでしたからね
やっぱり高校生の時は辞書をまるっきり暗記したんだと
だからもう何冊かも買います
一つ持って勉強してるけど
それはもうぐちゃぐちゃになるんだから
このページがまたもう破るんだそうです
1ページを勉強したら
それを破って捨てて またそれぐらい苦労して英語を勉強してるんだけど
全然英語わからないんですね
喋れない 書けない それで私は自分のことを思い出して
全くあれのももう百分率やってないんだと
辞書を暗記すると思ったこともない
それで単語なんかリスト書いて一つこうだこうだと覚えたが一度もないんです
たまに言われたことあるんですよ
これはもう覚えておけと
はい わかりましたって全然覚えていかないんです
僕はそのうち自然に覚えられるだろうと
何回使うと 何回か使うと
それはその時に私は使うんですね
もう新しい単語っていうのは
それで同じ単語っていうのは
どうせどんな文章でも何回も繰り返して繰り返してくる
そうするともう経験はもう生まれているんですね
それでその言葉は OK だと
例えば皆様が英語がわからないかもしれません
パパラッチという言葉知ってるんですね
なんであれ知ってるんですかね
あれは新しい英語なのに
辞書にもないし そんな経験なんですよ
なんかこのどんな場面でその言葉を使うかと知ってるんです
[背景音楽]経験で英語はできないんだけど
パパラッチ日本語の発音の分かりませんだけどね
ですぐ知ってる 言った途端
ですからそういう風にこの
なんていうか 知恵の働き使うと
まあ記憶力っていうのはまあ問題にならないというかね
もうすぐ使える思い出せるということがあるんです
思い出す思い出すってのは過去を思い出すことだから難しいんですよ
過去じゃなくていつでも現在になっちゃいけないんですね
今の瞬間に まあそういうことで
まあですからこの体のことからそこまで言う必要は全くないんですけど
それは言ったのは体では感じるのは重さじゃなくて
何て言いますか まあ物の硬さと温度だけですよと
この硬さについて軽いやら重いやらいろんなものを言うんだと
で 重い軽いというと まあそれは妄想概念であって
もう自分が何か過去の経験を基準にして喋っているんだと
その基準すぐ思い出せるならば
そこで記憶力の問題を解決するんですよということを言いたかったんです
日常生活で喋る時は 自分がもうすぐこれは綺麗だと言うんじゃなくて
なんで綺麗と言うんですかと
すぐそれを理解する その訓練ちょっとやってみちゃうと
もう教育の問題は解決する
すごい知恵が出てくるんです
そこで十に戻ります まあ時間はもう取りますけど
で えーと そこでこのこの反応
目 耳 鼻 口 体 それから意識
心 常に何かに反応する
その反応に十と言うんですよ
反応は知識じゃないんです
認識じゃないんです まだ知ったわけじゃないんです
音に反応して音を聞くんですよ
ですから感じることだと仏教で言えば正しいんですよ
敏感というか敏感じゃなくて sensitive
sensitive といえば
やっぱり感受性でしょうね
やっぱり中村先生の言葉はぴったし
まあ感受性なんですね
sensitive 耳が音に sensitive
感受性を持っていて 目が形に sensitive
この sensitive 感受性
仏教で十とvedanāと言うんです
それで仏教の世界はなんでそのこれはキーワードでそこまで大事かというと
それは生命なんでしょうね
感じる こと 感受性こそ生命なんですよ
その働き そこで我々は喋る
考える 哲学を作る 宗教を作る
経済学を作る 国を作るとか
美術的ないろんなことを
ものを作るとか 音楽を作るとか
どこから生まれるんですかね
全部 何か感じてやってるでしょうに
何か感じて喋っている
何か感じて考えている
何か感じてもう何かしている
だから人が例えば四十冊
五十冊ぐらい膨大な哲学のテキストを書いたんだと
すごい哲学者で頭が良くて
ああだこうだとか言ったっても
分かりやすく言えばその人の意識で何か感じているんだと
それで我々はまた騙されちゃうんだ
やっぱりすごいことを感じているのではないかと
そこでそうじゃないんですよ
耳で感じるものは決まってて音だけ
目で感じるものは決まっていて光だけと
意識で何を感じるんですかね
大したこと感じないんですよ
経験 聞いた音 過去になったところで聞いた音を感じるんです
見た形をまたさらに感じるんですよ
ほとんど過去のことなんですよ
起きた出来事を感じているんですよ
胃では過去も現在も感じることができます
あるものもないものも感じることできます
意識では いわゆる反応することだからね
そういうふうに仏教ではこの六つの感受性にどんな対象が触れたら反応するかと
というふうに分けているんです
そういうことで 全く世の中の宗教と哲学の流れには入らないんです
人間がもうどのように知るかという学問であって
知ってるものが有無んじゃないの
あの人知ってること正しいこと
この人知ってること間違ってるとか
そういうことじゃないんです
だからこの感じるところから見れば
大したことはないんですよ
例えば井戸の中にいるもうカラスであろうとも
もう世界中毎日回っている人であろうとも
いろんなことを見ているんだと言っても
別にどっちでも同じことなんですよ
形を目で見ていると 井戸の中にいるカエルさんがそこら辺の形を見ている
ずっと見ている で 地球を回っている人はその時その時目に入ることを見ている
まあ基本的には要はこれだけではないかと
そこで感じなきゃそこに生命はいません
感受性なければもう生命ではないんです
だから生命の定義っていうのは感受性なんですよ
結局は 感受性あるところは生命なんです
ですから 我々知っているのは物体で
感受性ある物体は生命体で
感受性がない物体は物体で
じゃあ物体がなくて感じるならば
それだったら体がない生命だと
それは体を持たない生命だ
それだけのこと で こちらではこの自分の説明の場合はその説明ではなくて
この感じるもの 何を感じるかということを
何に反応するんじゃなくて
何を感じるかと言えるんでしょうかね
そこを言ってるんですよ
そこはまた随分面白く
簡単単純なんですね 感受性は三つですよと
スカーヴェーダナ スカン
ドゥッカン アドゥッカマスカーティ
生命体が外の世界 内なる世界へ
外なる世界 どっちでも感じてますけど
何を感じるかというと
感じるのはスッカ ドゥッカ
アドゥッカマスカーティ三つだけ
いわゆる苦しみを感じる
楽を感じる あるいは不苦不楽を感じる
感じるのはその三つだけなんです
耳に音が触れたら あ 感じたと
聞こえたという前に 前じゃなくて同時ですけど
これは苦か楽か不苦不楽かどっちか感じているんですよ
だから我々はいつでもフィーリングとして
感受性として 生きている間では苦しみを感じる
楽しみを感じる あるいは不苦不楽を感じる
不苦不楽というのはウペッカーなんですね
パーリ語では スッカ ドッカ
アドッカマスカカというし
ウペッカーでもいいし
その三つですね だからこれだけ理解すれば
ヴィパッサナーは今までの随分難しい勉強なくてもできるんです
これはもう仏教のもう仏教哲学
お釈迦様の哲学の魂心に入ってるんです
お経はもうとことんきめ細かく砕いて読んでみてください
で お釈迦様のすべての人の批判であろうか
宗教の分析であろうが
輪廻の説明であろうが
もうここを中心にしてるんです
感受性 ウェーダナ 全てはここ
そこから始まるんだと
ということで そこで何を感じているかというと
苦を感じる 楽を感じる
不苦不楽を感じる ということで
世の中のもう神様であろうか
そうでなかろうが もう生命だったらたったそれしか感じてないんですよ
たったそれしか だからそこで楽になるんです
別にもうすごい気楽ですよ
あの人すごいことを言ってる
あの人はこのあの人 この人
こうだ ああだとか みんな必死になって追っかけてるでしょうに
世の中で走ってるわ 走ってるわ
あの人は超能力持ってるから聞いたらすぐそこに走っていって
もういいえ あれはダメだ
インチキ また他の人 あの人は超能力で癌が治ってくるんだとそこに走ってきた
治らなかった 他のところに行こうとかね
他の超能力者に下がったりとかね
で 日本の経済状態は悪んだから悪いんだから
いろんな経済専門家に聞こうとか
その人にあの人に聞く
やっぱり外国人の人に聞くと
みんないろんなものに走っていくんですよ
そこでどちらが正しいかどうかとか
すごいややこしい幻想の世界
妄想の世界を作って苦しんでるだけで
基本的に言えばみんなに眼耳鼻舌身意があって
そこで反応するし 反応するのは苦・楽・不苦不楽
その３つしかない その反応から妄想していろんなことを言うんですね
経済状態悪いって誰もそこはわからないんですよ
結局は 何かで何かに反応する
そこをちゃんと見るとそこを発見できますよ
だから人の話はその立場で
このちょっと上の立場から見ると
もう全部見えちゃうんです
全部もうバラバラになっちゃって見えてくるんです
下から上見ちゃうと もう本当に苦しいんですよ
この人すごい天才ですねとかね
あの それは主観的に見ているんだから
客観的に見ちゃうと もう天才でももうバカでも誰もがなくなっちゃうんですよ
みんな同じなんです 例えばもう 21 世紀の経済状態
大変だ もうビッグバンですか
もう始まらなくちゃいけないんだ
バカな人は食えればいいんじゃないかという
どっちでも同じなんだよ
結局は あんたそんなにいい加減で本当に大丈夫かとか困ったり
それは主観的な連中なんですよ
ビッグバンなんかどうでもいいんだけど
食えればいいやと思う人も
もう普通の生命体であって
いろんな分析するビッグバン論を喋っている人も
もうただの生命体であって
どれぐらい妄想しているかというぐらいのことなんですよ
それで解決を見つからないのはまた当たり前であって
みんな解決法っていうのは妄想の中でどんな妄想はいいかっていうぐらいのことだから
だからこの妄想はいいよと選んだものは妄想で
所詮妄想だから ある時間経っちゃうとそれは効かなくなっちゃうし
とにかくこの瞑想の立場から見ると
体がものを感じている
その体が実際に感じるのは苦か楽か不苦不楽かという 3つだけということを知っておけば
すべての真理を知る鍵にそれになるんです
ですからキーワードなんですよ
で  3つは足らないというならば
5つに分けることもできます
大した意味がないんですけど
こちらは何といいますか
5つに分ける場合は 楽・苦・喜・憂・捨に分けているんです
スッカ・ドッカ・ソーマナッサ・ドーマナッサ・ウペッカー
まあ 3つでも 5つでもそんな差がないんですよ
5つに分ける場合は スッカ・楽というのは体で感じる楽なんですね
ドッカというのは体で感じる苦しみなんですね
喜というのは心で感じる楽しみなんですね
憂というのは心で感じる苦しみなんですね
だからこの苦楽を体と心に分けただけのこと
それで苦楽を 4つになったんですよ
感じるのは苦と楽だよと言ったら
別に 2つしかないし 体で感じる苦楽と心で感じる苦楽にしちゃったら 2つになるだけ
それで言葉 4つを当てているんですね
捨はどっちでも捨なんです
まあもっとうるさく言うならば
捨は 2つ  2つなければいけませんではないかと言えますけどね
やっぱり使ってないんですね
なぜならば 体で感じる捨と心で感じる捨は確実にあるんだから
それだったら でもそれはあまり意味がないんだから
ウペッカーにしているんです
その 3つか 5つしか感じない
そこはたった一つの真理なんですよ
分かりますかね？真理として見ると
ウェーダナーというのはたった一つの真理なんです
この今日一切真珠に出てくる 2番目
パッサウェーダナー 即
リストに見てください
1番目は即  2番目は柔
真珠のリストの 2番目
たった一つの真珠に基づいて
この存在のからくりを回っているんですよ
幻想の世界で 妄想の世界で
だから なぜ仏教は他の宗教と別れているかというと
そのからくりは解明していないんですよ
自分の問題 例えばヒンドゥー教というのは
それはそれなりにすごい素晴らしい精神世界を教えているし
瞑想の世界もあるし 修行もあるし
もう素晴らしいんだけど
一人もこの自分という問題には当たってないんです
サマーディのことはきめ細かくしゃべる
瞑想は別に宗教の区別は瞑想の世界にあまりなかったんだから
大体このヨーガターサだとかね
そちらの説明も仏教の説明もそれほど差がないと言えばないんですよ
瞑想のやり方やらあれこれだってそんなに差がないんだけど
問題は何に何のために瞑想するか
何を体験するかとかいうことで
みんなこの自分の問題は置いといて
私はここでいるんだと
生命体だと 私がいるということはもう神様もいるということではないかということで
その真理の存在を体験しようということは
自分を感じようということでしょうに
何かを感じようとしているんですよ
体験っていうのは感受なんですよ
感受性 体験なんです 何か感じてみようと
ですから  自分の問題解決してないんだから
そういうことで なかなか一緒にはならないんですね
お釈迦様の教えは で 真理の中ではたった一つの真理
ヴェーダナっていう でもそれを共有した真理だから
全ての心にあるんです
だからそれ発見できるのはもうなかなか人間には発見できて
それを乗り越えるということはもう大変な仕事なんです
なぜならば 悟ることさえも心でやらなくちゃいけないんだから
その心に確実に自分があるんだから
うん まあ大体そういうことで
で 次に出てくるのはどんな心に
あの 苦あるか どんな心に楽あるかという心の分析なんですね
それもあのチャート見ればわからないかな
他のチャートあるんですかね
それは知っても知らなくたっても
まあそんなに あ あります
この八十九ページ 八十九ページのチャートのこの
この受の節というところがあって
そこでまあどんな受かということは書いているんですね
ですから そこら辺 あの
一つ一つ言うようになっちゃうと
皆様あまりこの 皆様日本語で覚えちゃうと
私がパーリ語しか覚えていないんだから難しい
説明するのは 例えば 痴愚の心はどうかと言えば
まあ貪瞋痴の四つがありますし
欲界心の十二があるんだとかね
粗・細・不定の八十八の智慧で
まあ一応受はそれで終了にします
[背景の雑音]